my body is ready to eat bunch of food
here at home shabu in Koreatown Los
Angeles we're back to do some spicy food
challenge here oh so you never tried hot
I've never had hot publisher in general
endeavour I'm glad that I'm starting it
out with a spicy challenge all right so
we got meat seafood raw veggies I saw I
was like a beast like there's everything
you need here I'm gonna bring everyone
I've ever known we should do a challenge
where one person eats like all of it
yeah why he's nominated herself
apparently this the white one is a
spicier one yeah which is weird cause it
doesn't look spicy at all I'll show the
brothers yeah it's kind of like a like a
long but it's good well--don't very much
I come bring all right now that spicy
one I smell the spicy it smells almost
like jalapeno yeah like what like
straight-up a lot of spicy foods that we
ate usually yeah this was just like it
see on the face but then it slides
ranger
you're like full-on mouth explosion of
spice thank you
alright let's just put in
brothers it's spicy yeah it's so good
like I can't stop drinking it it's
pretty sure I could smell and taste that
it's based off of peppers
oh yeah it's sweet peppers yeah helping
girls it goes so well maybe with me to
meet soaks in the soup that brought it
really well this is the opposite of and
every other challenge we've done so you
can't you want her like I want to stop
if I came here with friends I would get
the mild really I could miss spicy
better I'd get one of each so I have
other friends that are lame that get the
later right yeah no I'm just closer to
it who I liked watching Kevin suffer
it's funny Evan crying is the best kind
of doubted it when it was white man
you're not in just fighting for this
would be so I love the pain weird
okay I like painted yeah is this now
becoming an eating challenge like can we
finish all of this between the three oh
yeah what I wanted this is number two
all you kids all-you-can-eat yes this is
it all you can eat meat - oh yeah
everything so he can eat whoa
faith wise it was you could handle it
you know it's not like a dying spice I'm
still very spicy it takes you in the
throat in the beginning delicious yes
spicy yes
a man a few words little R Evan
[Music]